ALL RIGHT, CHRIS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FASCINATING AND DISTURBING AT
THE SAME TIME.
DEMOCRATS OBSESSION WITH
PROPPING UP FAILURE DOESN’T END
WITH PROPPING UP ELECTION LAWS.
THEIR $1.9 TRILLION "RELIEF
BILL" BAILS OUT WILDLY
IRRESPONSIBLE BLUE STATES AND
CITIES, INCLUDING, OF COURSE,
PELOSI’S HOMETOWN OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE CHRONICLE REPORTING THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGE WILL
ERASE THE MAJORITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO’S PROJECTED
$650 MILLION BUDGET DEFICIT OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
SAVING CITY HALL FROM HAVING TO
MAKE PAINFUL SERVICE CUTS AND
LAYOFFS.
WHAT THIS REALLY MEANS THAT THE
OLD MAN’S PALS RUNNING
SAN FRANCISCO WILL BE SPARED THE
PAIN OF GETTING BOOTED FROM
OFFICE FOR THEIR COMPLETE
INCOMPETENCE.
JOINING ME NOW HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS REALLY
REWARDING FAILURE ACROSS THE
BOARD.
IT’S NOT SO MUCH HELPING
VULNERABLE PEOPLE AS HELPING
VULNERABLE POLITICIANS.
>> ACTUALLY IT REWARDS BAD
BEHAVIOR, IT’S A BAY AREA
BAILOUT.
THINK ABOUT THAT, SAN FRANCISCO
HAS A $650 MILLION DEFICIT AND
THEY’RE GETTING $600 MILLION.
WHAT DO SAN FRANCISCO SPENT PART
OF THEIR MONEY ON?
PUTTING HOMELESS IN HOTELS,
PAYING FOR THEIR ALCOHOL, PAYING
FOR THEIR MARIJUANA.
THIS BILL ALSO DO YOU KNOW WHAT
IT DOES?
IT GIVES FEDERAL EMPLOYEES UP TO
$21,000 PAID LEAVE.
THEY’VE NEVER BEEN LAID OFF.
STATE EMPLOYEES CAN GET UP TO
$25,000 BONUSES.
IT TAKES CARE OF THE SWAP.
IT GOES IN AND IT ADDS MONEY TO
PAY FOR THE HEALTH CARE OF
ILLEGALS, AND REMEMBER, THEY TRY
TO SAY THIS HAPPENS WITH COVID.
LESS THAN 9% OF THIS BILL DOES
ANYTHING FOR COVID.
AND IT REWARDS THE STATES WITH
BAD BEHAVIOR.
IT LITERALLY CHANGES THE FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR STATES GETTING
MONEY IN AMERICA.
IT REWARDS STATES THAT SHUT
DOWN, IT REWARDS STATES THAT
HAVE PENSION PROBLEMS INSTEAD OF
A FAIR PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE
NATION.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
NANCY PELOSI HER BECAUSE SHE WAS
ASKED ABOUT WHETHER THERE WOULD
BE MORE BILLS LIKE THIS COVID
BILL.
THAT MEANS MORE TRILLION DOLLAR
TYPE -- YOU KNOW, PIECES OF
LEGISLATION, CONGRESSMAN, AND
THIS IS HOW IT WENT DOWN.
WATCH.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS IS THE LAST
PRIMARILY COVID BILL THAT YOU’LL
HAVE TO TAKE UP?
>> YOU’RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
ASK THE VIRUS.
IF IT STOPS MUTATING, AS IT
STOPS SPREADING AND THEREFORE
MUTATING, THEN JUST SEE WHERE
YOU ARE THEN BUT IT’S NOT
ANYTHING ANYBODY CAN PREDICT.
IT’S JUST A QUESTION OF THE
SCIENCE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, MY
BREATH IS TAKEN AWAY.
SHE’S SAYING IT DEPENDS ON THE
VIRUS’ MUTATION.
SHE DOESN’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IMMUNOLOGY, EVERYTHING.
ANYTHING ABOVE THE VIRUS IS
CLEARLY LESS LETHAL THAN IT WAS
A YEAR AGO, BUT SHE WAS THE DOOR
OPEN TO MORE SPENDING, MEANING
THE STATES CAN STAY LOCKED DOWN
IN THE FALL -- CLOSED-CIRCUIT
SCHOOLING.
>> WOULD YOU EXPECT ANY ANSWER
FROM ANY OTHER SOCIALIST?
YOU WILL EVENTUALLY RUN OUT OF
EVERYBODY ELSE’S MONEY AND
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
THIS 1.9 TRILLION.
THIS MONEY DOES NOTHING TO PUT
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK, BACK TO
SCHOOL, OR BACK TO HEALTH.
IT USES IT TO REWARD THOSE THAT
THEY CARE MOST ABOUT.
THE MISMANAGEMENT OF STATES
ACROSS THIS NATION, TO REWARD
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN LAID OFF.
$21,000.
OR STATE EMPLOYEES, A $25,000
BONUS.
THAT IS WORKING TAXPAYERS MONEY.
IT IS COSTING EVERY FAMILY MORE
THAN $5,000 AND A FEW PEOPLE
WILL GET A $1400 CHECK.
IT’S ONE OF THOSE CRAZY EMAILS
YOU GET FROM ANOTHER NATION.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY THINK THEY CAN
BUY OFF VOTERS IN 2022.
THAT’S WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE.
THEY SPEND ENOUGH, THE PRINT
ENOUGH MONEY, BORROW ENOUGH FROM
JAPAN OR CHINA OR WHEREVER THEY
ARE BORROWING IT FROM THESE
DAYS, AND JUST PRINTING IT, THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO BUY VOTERS OFF.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GET USED TO BEING,
SADLY, ON THE FEDERAL GOAL?
>> I’M CONCERNED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WHAT WE’RE FINDING TODAY
TODAY, BY CONTINUING TO PAY MORE
FOR PEOPLE ARE UNEMPLOYED AND
NOT EATING THEM INCENTIVE TO GO
BACK TO WORK, YOU FIND THIS TIME
AND AGAIN, WHERE’S THE
ACCOUNTABILITY?
WHERE IS THE WORK INCENTIVE TO
GET PEOPLE WORKING AGAIN?
THAT’S WHAT WE’D LIKE TO SEE
GOING FORWARD, BUT AGAIN, THE
DEMOCRATS FIND NO OTHER WAY THAN
TO PROVIDE CHECKS OUT AND I’M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BUT I TRUST
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
WE WOULD RATHER WORK THAN HAVE A
GOVERNMENT JUST PAY US.
WE’D RATHER HAVE A BETTER FUTURE
AND WOULD RATHER NOT SACRIFICE
OUR CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN’S
FUTURES FOR OUR WASTING OF MONEY
TODAY.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, IT
LOOKS LIKE TWO MORE MONTHS OF
RAZOR WIRE AND NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS AROUND THE CAPITAL AND I
THINK WE CAN DO TO SHUT THAT
DOWN OR THAT’S GOING TO DEPEND
ON THE VIRUS’ MENTATION AS WELL?
>> NO, IT SHOULD NOT.
THERE’S NO THREAT.
I MEAN, THINK OF THE HYPOCRISY.
THAT IS THE HYPOCRISY WALL.
THEY WILL NOT PROTECT THE
BORDER.
THEY WANT TO TAKE A WALL DOWN
AROUND THE BORDER BUT THEY WANT
TO PUT A WALL DOWN AROUND THE
PEOPLE’S HOUSE?
THAT NATIONAL GUARD, DO YOU KNOW
IF THE NATIONAL GUARD SITTING UP
THERE SEE SOMEBODY CLIMBING THE
WALL, THEY CAN’T DO ANYTHING,
THEY HAVE TO CALL THE CAPITOL
POLICE.
THAT WALL NEEDS TO COME DOWN,
THE PEOPLE NEED TO BE INVITED
BACK IN, AND WE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR BORDERS AND LET THE PEOPLE
GET BACK TO WORK AND BACK TO
SCHOOL.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, THERE